[Musique]
et voici Jeanne vauvernier
dites l'ange
tombé du ciel
je vous attendais moi
[Musique]
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il serait temps de
changer de vie pour aller où Jean dubary
veut que je vous présente au roi
[Applaudissements]
la comtesse jade du Barry
surtout
ne regardez pas le roi dans les yeux ce
serait perçu par la cour comme une
invitation
à quoi à la baguette
[Musique]
père nous sommes devenus la risée de
Versailles à cause de vos égarements le
Premier ministre ne va pas tolérer que
vous laissiez une fille des rues côtoyez
votre entourage c'est une femme et mon
entourage
[Musique]
je vous aime
sur vous pour que cette misérable femme
soit chassée de la Cour
le Roi d'autres maîtresse est en train
de découvrir
le côté sombre du roi
[Musique]